welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens a new rock stars asked
me the resident creep if I can spot and
rank every disturbing gruesome god-awful
moment in the MCU and I said who me
easily so today I'll be sharing the most
disturbing moments that took us all by
storm and arguably shouldn't have been
seen I love scary stuff you guys but
some stuff we kind of Let Go by the
wayside and they have huge complications
over time though most of these scenes
are more horrifying than disturbing
there's something deep down that's
enticing about them so let's talk about
it starting off with the toilet Goo now
is it disturbing to me not so much but I
know y'all would eat me alive if I
didn't include the toilet goo man in the
first Ant-Man movie this poor man just
had some concerns and he didn't know
he'd be turned into diarrhea we also
don't know if he felt being turned into
a pile of mush and mopped up from the
floor but nonetheless it was very
unsettling Doctor Strange Multiverse of
Madness is such a Sam Raimi piece that
even disturbing parts are kinda silly
which I love but some scenes got pretty
disturbing or dark Doctor Strange
literally reanimates himself like that's
it not even cool sick either just like
disgusting it's filthy as hell we know
the toll it takes on you to even do that
but the man's said the only body I have
left in this universe is well the Dead
one looks like I'm strolling in like a
zombie like it's it's just it's filthy
it's disgusting when you really think
about not only did he have to bury
himself but he had to walk around in his
own like dead suit it gives me the same
eerie and icky feeling as when like Rick
and Morty takes the place of their dead
versions of themselves and they have to
bury it it's just like gross and also
Wanda cracking her body through the
mirror was the most up thing I've
ever seen and it still haunts me in my
nightmares coming up third from the
bottom is a black panther killmonger
doesn't only Mark himself for every kill
he acquires which makes it a very
disturbing plot but in the quickest
scene he literally chokes out an old
lady this scene right here killmonger is
seen as the antagonist but with every
extra little detail we can believe he's
still Justified or at least you know
fighting for something good but what
he's definitely not justified in is
choking this older lady that's insane if
he was choking me that'd be a different
story but he isn't he's choking this
older lady so we're moving on next on my
list is Antonio Drake off AKA Taskmaster
basically died from her father's
assassination attempt when Natasha set
off a bomb exploding draco's daughter's
face yes it's horrible Natasha believe
she killed the young daughter of her
enemy but what's even more horrific is
her father turned her into a weapon
placing a chip gnulling her senses in
the back of her neck creating the
world's best mimic instead of letting
nature run its course he took his
daughter and made her into a robot I can
compare this moment to any Black Mirror
where they made a clone of a dead person
or even in Pet Cemetery where the child
dies is only brought back for chaos it's
truly the act of saving your daughter
just to make her work for you and kill
people without consent that makes this
completely disturbing next on my list is
in the first Iron Man movie we see the
horrific scene of the Sonic stun gun
used by Obadiah sting we see Tony's
veins pop out of his face I think he
begins to turn white and we see him
literally dying the stun gun was created
by Stark Industries to incapacitate an
enemy this wasn't approved by the
government but was used by Obadiah twice
he then pulls Tony's Arc Reactor from
his chest leaving him to slowly die this
scene is morbid it looks horrified it's
completely disturbing especially seeing
a half dead Tony crawl for help it's the
essence of like a True Villain giving a
monologue while killing the number one
hero that makes it disturbing and
watching someone get get their heart
ripped out of their chest while alive
and flaunted in front of them we're
seeing a darker side to humanity here
through obadiah's day now you know this
how to make it to the list it just
wasn't at the very top but in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 the entire movie is
disturbing but overall the icing on the
cake
is ego giving Quill's mom cancer in the
process of creating a Celestial powered
child ego's entire deal was remaking the
universe in his own image by planting
seedlings on different planets and
taking it over as new extensions of
himself he realized this was way too
hard to do himself so he needed to make
someone with similar Powers able to
assist so he needed desire a child he
would literally produce thousands of
children with different life forms on
different planets and hired yandu to
collect some of them and the ones that
didn't produce the celestial power were
killed which was all of them but mantis
and Peter that we know of Eagle
purposefully killed Quill's mom by
planting a tumor in her brain and this
is horrific all of it is disturbing I
think equally disturbing and enticing to
us is the remorse he has for doing all
of it in his eyes it was for his goals
which were warranted and he's truly a
lunatic next on my list is Avengers Age
of Ultron which had ton of disturbing
scenes that people forget about because
a the movie came out a minute ago and B
was super quick so let's remember
Wanda's first villainous task which was
making the Avengers see horrifying
things specifically Natasha Romanov
having to relive the trauma of the Red
Room it flashes between scenes of girls
dancing and ballet and walking through
the halls but a woman tells Natasha
you're automated Marvel
we'll celebrate after the graduation
ceremony then we flash to her shooting a
Target that's actually a man strung up
with a hood over his head the young
girls were clearly abused and unable to
see reality for most of it we learn of
their involuntary hysterectomies and
Wanda literally makes her relive her
worst nightmare it's heavy and pretty
disturbing and I sometimes forget it
happened we flash between scenes of the
medical equipment needed and young
Natasha and White hospital gowns and
it's all quick blur of trauma and thank
God Clint stops her and one of the first
appearances we meet Wanda we see her as
a supremely unfiltered villain this one
should be closer to the top I'll I won't
argue because it hurts me I love a good
villain you guys and I love true crime
stories but what I do hate are found
footage of True Crime activities which
we straight up see in Civil War and
Bucky kill Tony's parents Zemo killed
the remaining Winter Soldiers at the
Hydra facility and once Iron Man Bucky
and Captain America arrived he calmly
put a video of Tony Stark's parents
being murdered on the added disturbing
bonus was Baron Zemo forcing Tony to
watch his parents get killed in the same
room as Bucky who killed his parents we
watched the Collision then Howard Stark
crawls out of the car only to be punched
in the face repeatedly then Tony's mom
strangled how many times do we have to
see Tony in despair this had to be on
the list very high on this list and I
think people kind of forget about it is
in Doctor Strange's post-credits scene
we see one of the most horrible acts
from mordo after Pangborn was paralyzed
from an accident at the factory he
worked at he made his way to carmetage
where he learned Magic from the ancient
one and used that magic to give him the
power to walk again at the end of the
movie mordo went to penguin and stripped
him of his powers causing him to be
paralyzed again this man did absolutely
nothing he learned just like mordo did
from the ancient one and went back to
living his life just to have it taken
away from him again now this scene
struck me completely as horrific and
disturbing but people forget this scene
exists because the next time we see
mordo he's not stripping people of their
powers he's an 838 playing in the leader
I'm a big fan of being my best self and
Beyond filling my brain with fun things
to think about dogs wearing pants
hamsters and top hats the usual I also
like to take care of my body and if you
like taking care of your body You're
Gonna Want to fully tune in because
we're gonna have one of the best offers
we've ever given on this channel thanks
to geology geology is an 18 time
award-winning skin air and body care
company recognizing Men's Health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology creates simple and effective
skin care and Hair Care routines
customized just for you with ingredients
that are proven to work their products
are built around just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades and you need to trust
dermatologists don't go to tick tock
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology will create a simple
and effective skin care or hair care
routine customized just for you with
ingredients that our dermatologist has
had proven to work and personalized to
your needs Johnny's got you covered no
matter how you're looking to up your
personal care game but right now we're
running with a special offer for a
skincare sampler pack which is great
because their skin care stuff rules
geology's line of skin care products can
help you fight acne reduce oiliness
prevent wrinkles combat dark and puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging personally I'm
a fan of their vitamin c and e fioric
acid serum but I also use everything
else because I am old and I look like a
witch normally geology has co-wash for
your hair body wash for your body and
deodorant for your odors whatever you
need geology has you covered there has
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a limited time use
code new rockstars 100 to get 100 off
your personalized 30-day skincare sample
set all you have to do is cover the 495
for shipping that's like the same price
as a Happy Meal this is hands down the
best deal that is out there and on top
of that new Rockstar's fans get an
exclusive bonus offer up to 50 off in
additional skin hair and body product of
your choice when you add it to your
trial click the link in the description
or go to geology
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started next on the list is
Avengers Infinity War there's a ton of
scenes I found disturbing you guys
nebula has a ton of disturbing moments
in the MCU because the poor girl's been
tortured her entire life and seeing the
torture in Infinity War didn't make it
any better Thanos took her apart in
front of Gamora to get Gamora to talk
when he pulls nebula Apart Her screams
rip through the speakers and through our
hearts
nebula is one of the strongest women in
the MCU so seeing this is outwardly
despicable and so awful and just
completely disturbing the second part is
the killing of vision then we watch him
die again after he says this it's all
right
you could never hurt me we immediately
see this seeing anyone brought back to
die again is a massive horrifying
disturbing experience I don't wish the
amount of death strange or vision went
through on anybody lastly is the dusting
of Peter Parker the sadness and shock of
feeling like we really saw Tom Holland
dying it's really hearing a young man go
please please I don't want to go that
took me out of the movie and into oh
buddy please got the children and of
course next on my list would come
Avengers end game Tony Stark dying is
horrific but is it disturbing when we
already saw him get his heart taken out
of him in the first Army movie I don't
think so what was disturbing for me and
end game was nebula having to shut her
father's eyes after Thor decapitates him
in any scene truthfully where nebula is
in the same room with Thanos as
disturbing seeing as he took her apart
and replaced Major limbs with mid-tech
well beyond her consent so she's
constantly sharing a room with her
torturer and this time when he's
apologizing she's left with a headless
father the decapitation scene was really
like oh okay okay MC you were going
there so it's more than just that the
last seed we had with them literally was
him torturing her for Gamora to spill
details and even here I don't think she
loves Thanos I don't think she's doing
this out of love but she still
recognizes him as a father that shaped
her into the mess that she is today
every single episode of wand division
was disturbing and that's why it's
rightfully this high on the list and
here are my top moments seeing dead
vision and dead Pietro we've seen them
dead before Vision died twice by now and
Pietro died by hurricane a bulletin Age
of Ultron when memories of them pop back
up for Wanda and her days we get these
horrifying scenes of their dead selves
well the holes in the shirt for Pietro
but lifeless pale Vision missing his
Stone his body resembles exactly the way
Thanos left it it was a jump scare and
very disturbing additionally Brandon
here Brandon Barrick has made this point
time and time again and I agree with him
what happens to the people of Westview
that have peanut allergies and are
forced to eat peanut butter sandwiches
it's not like their body knows they're
under a hex the same goes for when
Dottie breaks the glass in her hand
cutting herself or to stop it stop it
scene when she makes the man choke she's
straight up making that man choke every
time the people of Westview come out of
the hex it's completely a disturbing
scene and so is the idea that Wanda is
controlling children I I gotta say it
number two on my list is Moon night and
unfortunately Moon Knight's relationship
with her mother more horrific was Moon
Knight's upbringing dealing with child
abuse in the Disney MCU we don't really
see stories that physical abuse and
Trauma to this degree now I recognize
that like the widows and basically all
of the guardians of the galaxies and
even Shang chi have all been through
similar childhood abuse but they didn't
really show it to the extent of moon
nights we know this contributed to his
did and the scenes where he has to
witness what happened to him all over
again was extremely painful and pretty
disturbing to watch number one on my
listen is because I had to go back and
watch it you guys please don't do it I
speak on this a lot but after Lamar dies
and Falcon and the Winter Soldier our
boy U.S agent very heated immediately
chases down a flag Smasher and smashes
their chest in with the Captain America
shield this scene gave off literal
Guillotine Vibes imagine you're back in
the day a public execution Guillotine
like that's what we got and normal
civilians are on the street recording it
on their phones I couldn't choose which
was more disturbing the public execution
or stabbing someone in the chest with
the Captain America shield until their
chest collapse so overall this scene
gets a solid 12 out of 10 on the
disturbing scale God Bless America am I
right boys oh I don't know us agent was
bad I also want to give a shout out to
our honorable mentions I love Jessica
Jones but the first season was
disturbing the villain was killgrave and
he had the ability to control people's
minds at will and exactly what you'd
expect a horrible person to do with
these Powers he in fact did he was
obsessed with Jessica Jones and
manipulated her for months kilgrave is a
true monster and a huge criminal and
villain his unwillingness to see his own
horrible actions was disgusting second
honorable mention goes to season three
of Daredevil more specifically anytime
we see bullseye bullseye had a rough
upbringing a rough start a rough ass
life and his obsession over this young
woman Julie Barnes only made it worse
then Fisk ripped everything from him his
job and then killed Julie he manipulated
Bullseye through it all but the most
disturbing part for me was when Bullseye
decided to take the Frozen corpse of
Julie Barnes who's not his girlfriend
puts her into the passenger seat of
their FBI car and pulls up the fist's
wedding it was wild as hell and
occasionally you kind of forget that he
did that but to be fair Bullseye had a
lot going on at all times and that's it
for my ranking on the mcu's most
disturbing moments let me know how you
feel about them in the comments make
sure to follow me at Lulu underscore
Clemens following Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars from a break sounds of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign